is also threatening the pawn and uh  if the queen is allowed to take the pawn  with check  nothing nothing can save white's h-born  there white's pawn in the corner also  under fire and  yeah it might be time to call it quits  yeah call it quits or  maybe white can try a couple of more  spike checks white can grab the black  knight  and once the rook drops off the board  you can take another pawn and just say  okay i'm going to lose but at least i've  checked you  i know when i was young that was that  was what a lot of people did they  just before they resign they say oh i've  checked you at least once  sometimes that's good enough it's some  consolation and  yeah napoli actually he just resigns and  he's out it's  over wesley so is ready for the final in  the fdx crypto cup  uh timor no sorry on the pognyacci he  resigns is over for him  the american is ready for his third  final in the meltwater champions chester  that is extremely  impressive stuff